welcome to the heavy spoilers show
i'm your host definition aka the guy
who's thinking of ending explaining
things
in this video we've got a lot to talk
about i just want to get straight into
the movie as
there's so many things to unpack but
obviously there will be heavy spoilers
here so if you haven't had a chance to
check it out yet then i highly recommend
that you check out now
make sure you subscribe to the channel
for videos like this every day and
please drop a thumbs up
if you enjoy it without the way thank
you for clicking this
now let's get into our breakdown of i'm
thinking of ending things
okay so on the surface the film seems
pretty straightforward
and its plot is relatively simple we
follow a woman named lucy
who travels to meet her boyfriend's
parents throughout the piece she's
haunted by the thought of ending things
and this is taken as her relationship
with her boyfriend jake
after a while at the house they decide
to leave and we watch as the pair
journey back to jake's high school
which is where he dies before performing
oklahoma on stage
okay maybe it's not that straightforward
now the movie is very much an art house
piece
and chances are you probably have a lot
of questions surrounding its true
meaning
and the symbolism behind it you don't
have to be a genius in order to
understand it
but to look at what the film is trying
to convey we have to look at the book
that the film is based on
the story written by ian reed actually
chronicles the thoughts that come to
one's head
just before ending their own life their
happy memories
their regrets and also what's brought
them to the conclusion that ending
things
is the only option left is truly
explored in this film
when one dies it is said that your life
flashes before your eyes
and the movie itself should be seen as a
continuous thought that's a compilation
of someone's memories of their life
this is exemplified in the aspect ratio
of the piece which is shot almost to
look like an old television show
presenting an almost nostalgic look at
the past for our characters
as they reminisce over things when we
think it's never normally one
straightforward thing
and the book itself says that you can't
fake a thought
our brain fires off continuously and
often
when we reminisce over things our
consciousness drifts from one point to
the next
the slip service paid to this in the
form of the poem owed by william
wordsworth
this chronicled someone's life and it is
poetic that jake decides to bring it up
wordsworth wrote a number of poems to a
woman named lucy who died very young
similar to how jake recounts his life to
his lover the book and the movie itself
both heavily imply that lucy is not a
real person and that she and jake
are actually one in the same in the
original work
she doesn't even really get a name and
she should be viewed as a manifestation
of jake's consciousness
that is journeying with him as he
recalls the past
several clues are dropped like jake
saying that his slippers are hers
and that she was brought up in a house
that's exactly like the one he grew up
in
she then later says she grew up in an
apartment and this of course contradicts
that
she also thinks that a photo of jake is
a photo of her and there are clues that
become
very apparent on a second watch now as
for what lucy represents i personally
believe that she's a lover of jake's
life
jake likely loved a lot of people in his
life and these relationships could also
be seen as his regrets
throughout the film there are several
representations in his journey of the
women in his life with the ice cream
stand being one of the most notable of
these
he's clearly intimidated by the girls
which we learn are from his high school
and they look at him in a very mocking
way due to his reaction when standing
there
i kind of get the feeling that this is
one of the many straws that
quote unquote broke the camel's back in
to cut with jake driving along
you also see shots of an old man which
should be seen as an older version of
jake
and it is possible that lucy was his
wife but that he lost her
jake's father says that he misses his
wife terribly and it could be hinting
jake sharing these emotions
there's a passage in which we hear the
lines there's either a wife
or a wife-shaped hole waiting for you
and it's really sad to see this
however lucy also gets a call from
someone called lucy
and with us knowing that jake and she
are the same it could be possible that
this lucy is calling
because she's worried about him lucy
could also be his daughter
and when a name flashes up on a phone
screen it's to announce that this is the
name of the person calling you
so there is a lot that we can read into
it there's several missed calls from
both lucy and louisa
both of which would be saved as the same
contact if they were the same person
and i do think that both his wife and
potentially his daughter lucy
are very worried about him now as a
janitor we can tell he's just existing
instead of living and he longs to be
seen once more
which teases why he performs oklahoma at
the end which we discover is his
favorite song
he's just going through identical days
the sun goes up and down
and he keeps getting older and i'm
realizing just how depressing this movie
is now throughout the car ride
lucy clearly thinks stark things but
when asked about this
she says an answer that makes it seem
like everything is fine
this of course represents depression and
often people have things going on
beneath the surface
that they simply don't express memory is
of course an unreliable
thing and often names faces and
appearances
change slightly depending on how we
record things in that moment
now this is hinted at throughout the
movie when we see some slightly jarring
things in his parents
when he first enters the house it looks
slightly older than when they have
dinner together
and throughout the time that they spend
there their age fluctuates with his
parents getting older and younger
seemingly without any explanation it's
quite subtle the first time we see it
but the more we get into the movie the
more it becomes obvious
now clearly they hint to what jake's
life was really like and it becomes
clear that on the farm he dealt with a
lot of death
this likely shaped his mentality and
it's almost like he's become completely
desensitized to it
i get the feeling that jake's parents
were never really there for him and that
he was often waiting on approval from
them which is represented by them taking
so long to come down the stairs his
father doesn't even look him in the eyes
as he shakes his hand
and clearly the relationship isn't
really there we learn that jake used to
paint too
and that his father pretty much looks
down his nose at lucy's art
i think they are probably well
intentioned but as with most parental
relationships
it takes a long time for children to
appreciate the things that their parents
do
they have a lot of conversations but
ultimately it doesn't seem like they're
fully on the same page
even the movie itself doesn't seem like
it's on the same page as itself
as it drifts off into other films and
yeah it's clear that jake's brain is
firing on all cylinders
as he tries to bring together his life
into one conscious thought
the basement is very much his
subconscious and it's here that we see
his works of art alongside the many
things that he tried to achieve
in life but was held back from and thus
had to leave behind
his work uniform is also there which we
later see the janitor wearing
which does hint at the pair being linked
jake's mother passes away
and he decides that it's time to go he
leaves his father behind
reminding lucy that they loved her even
though they might not have fully shown
it at the time
things get darker for the pair as they
head further into the night blizzard
and the memories change from being
focused on the happier ones to things
more critical which shows just how deep
jake is able to dissect the things
around him
and find negativity no matter what
jake's mind goes through the sayings
that we use to comfort ourselves in dark
times
but they don't really work and he still
continues his journey to the tulsi town
where one of the vendors tells lucy that
she doesn't have to go
whilst the other girls giggle away at
him there's a lot of subtext of the
conversation here
and it's at this point that everything
starts to come together
and we realize that this journey is
jake's final one
he truly becomes locked on this route to
the high school and from his
conversation about age
we can tell that he longs to be young
again like the students that he passes
every day
he realizes that that will never happen
for him and that he sees himself as
someone destined for the ashy
lucy argues with him that she's given
him so many reasons to return home
but in the end he doesn't and lucy heads
into the school after him
where she sees the janitor walking
through the halls
they have a really deep conversation
about things and relationships
and how men act and it may even
highlight that jake regrets the way he
acted in the past
this is also represented in the song
baby it's cold outside
which over the years has developed a lot
of negative connotations around it
in the end jake does agree that its
meaning is inappropriate
and it shows that he probably regrets
all the things that he did to lucy when
trying to approach her
we then watch as two actors step forward
in their place and perform at dances the
pair
showing the life that jake truly longed
for and the romance that he either
misses or wish that he had
it sort of tells our life story and how
they met were married
and that jake's job cast them apart
leading to lucy leaving him
this is just my interpretation of it and
i see the younger version of jake
fighting the older one
showing that he did want to come back
but ultimately his worst nature won
which led to lucy being taken by the
other again
this is just how i took it and we see as
the real older jake journeys out to his
truck
but instead of starting the engine he
decides to sit there in the blizzard
and just let himself get caught in the
weather as he reminisces over what's
come before
he slowly begins to lose it as it all
comes flooding back
and he climbs out into the snow to die
with the pig
that died on his farm when he was
younger we also see a scar in the middle
of his chest
and it could be that this is from the
stabbing which we see happen in the
dance
the movie culminates with him performing
oklahoma a moment that should be seen as
a swan song
as the character passes away in the snow
likely still stuck in his truck
that ends the film and jake's life but
what did i think of it
as a whole well before we get into that
i just want to let you know we're giving
away a free copy of the christopher
nolan collection to one random
subscriber
all you have to do to be on the chance
of winning is like the video subscribe
to the channel and leave your thoughts
on the film in the comment section below
the winner is going to be chosen at
random on the 30th of september and the
set will be shipped out from then to
ever gets the prize
so best of luck to everyone who takes
part okay
so this movie definitely won't be for
everyone and people who like
straightforward narratives and films
that aren't filled with metaphors
probably won't enjoy it i can imagine it
will be a difficult first watch
and one that they probably won't revisit
however
i absolutely loved it and seeing it
twice for this video
i think it all works really well in a
spellbinding way that makes it instantly
become one of the best movies of the
year
the film is very much a comment on life
and all its ups and downs
i think that many will find a lot that
they can relate to
there are sections i do think could have
been cut and i can imagine that some
will find it quite difficult to follow
but all the similes and metaphors make
this spellbinding in my opinion
and it truly is a great piece of art i'm
thinking of ending things
is phenomenal and it gets a 9.5 out of
10.
now obviously i'd love to hear your
thoughts on the film and what you took
from it
i can imagine that everyone's going to
have a completely different opinion on
it
so make sure you drop yours in the
comments below if you enjoy this video
and want to see a breakdown of today's
other big release
and make sure you check out our recap of
the first three episodes of the boys
which is going to be linked at the end
if you want to support the channel and
get to see content
early then please consider clicking the
join button below you can also come chat
to us on our discord server
linked in the description or heavy
spoilers on twitter thanks for making it
until the end of the video
you've been the best i've been
definition i'll see you next time
take care peace
[Music]
you